revenons maintenant sur ce dossier de la
contamination au plomb dans l'état du
michigan
une situation qui demeure très
troublante et d'autres villes
américaines ont aussi été aux prises
avec ce problème dans le passé il
faudrait que la situation au canada à
quel point est-ce qu'on est encore
exposés au plomb
alors pour le savoir c'est vide en fait
santé canada fait de temps à autre des
tests sur un échantillonnage de
canadiens la dernière fois c'était en
2011 et en 2011 en fait ils ont constaté
que 100 % des canadiens qui avaient été
testées âgés de 3 à 79 ans cent pour
cent des canadiens avaient des traces
détectables de plomb mais c'était bien
en-deça de la norme canadienne qui est
de moins de 0,01 mg par litre c'est déjà
très infime et la bonne nouvelle c'est
que ce taux enregistré en fait été
quatre fois plus faible qu'en 1978
maintenant ce plomb on le trouve où
mais en fait on le trouve un peu partout
il est par exemple dans l'air il est
dans l'eau il est dans le sol il dans
les poussières de notre maison ou encore
dans la consommation d'aliments que l'on
fait à des degrés divers
il y en avait aussi jusqu'il ya peu dans
les soudures de boîtes de conserve dans
les jouets et les bijoux de fantaisie
il y avait également du plomb dans les
fameuses peintures au plomb parce que
c'était très durable à l'époque et il y
en avait encore jusque dans les maisons
qui avaient été construites avant 1960
comment oui évidemment comment oublier
l'essence avec du plan qui a disparu
dans les années 90 et puis enfin c'est
important de le mentionner
il y avait aussi les fameuses entrée de
service là dans les canalisations
il y avait du plomb là dedans et c'était
encore dans les maisons construites
avant 1975 il s'était interdit par le
code de plomberie en 1980 mais encore
des tuyaux de plomb oui en fait on parle
surtout des entrées de service qui se
rendent jusque dans les maisons donc
servi la queue du cac votre maison est
régulièrement les municipalités
canadiennes procède à des vérifications
des analyses de l'eau est aussi ont des
programmes de remplacement en place par
exemple à montréal ils ont commencé à
faire cela en 2006 même si les risques
de contamination de l'eau par le plomb
était quand même relativement faibles
ils ont quand même été de là aller de
l'avant avec ce programme là et d'ici
donc 2016 2026 à la coûté environ 30
millions $ par année pour remplacer
toutes ces fameuses entrée de service
qui contenaient du plomb
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire alors pour
réduire notre exposition à ce métal
working toxiques mais en fait d'abord on
peut appeler la municipalité si on a des
doutes savoir s'il reste encore du plomb
dans le tuyau on peut faire des analyses
de l'eau il faut aussi surveiller les
enfants qui ont tendance à mettre
beaucoup de choses dans la bouche ans
ayant encore des jouets qui contiennent
du plan qui sont en circulation
enfin bref au toujours très être très
vigilant et puis surtout n'hésitez pas à
faire le ménage plus souvent parce que
croyez le ou non le plan se retrouve
aussi dans les poussières dans la maison
et vous le savez des enfants se promène
un peu partout
donc il en consomme pas ce qu'ils
mettent des nains dans la bouche bref un
petit peu de ménage ça enlève quand même
un peu de plomb et c'est important
bon conseil merci frédéric non plus